So the first statement is clearly true, and we talked about this a couple of times
in this unit.
If you know the state of the deterministic RAM,
that means you know whats in the memory
and where the program is currently executing,
then you can easily tell what the machine will do as a next step.
The second one is of course not true,
because we have the if-better function, and so
if we know the state of a non deterministic RAM at time point t,
and at that point in time, we call the if-better function,
then we can not say what the state will be
at time t plus 1.
There are basically either the first part of the code is executed
or the second part of the code is executed.
And this gives us the answer for
the last 3 statements here,
so this one here is false, because a non deterministic RAM
does not behave like a deterministic RAM,
but there is actually only one case where it does this,
and that is when if-better is called,
so this statement here is true,
and when the if-better is called, there can not be any number of next states.
There can only be 2,
because you'll remember, the if-better function works as follows.
You call if-better, then there's some code here,
and then you have an else statement, and there's some code here.
Then there's only 2 possibilities,
so it's not any number of states;
it is actually just 2,
so this is also false.